We are not the problem.
Do you have a question?
Hate speech does incite violence.
Black lives matter!
Yeah, gotcha.
These protesters don't want this man
to speak.
The speaker is Dave Rubin.
Hello internet, my name is Dave Rubin.
I am the newest host here
on The Young Turks.
He was once a leftist.
I obviously, I'm for Obamacare.
You and I both started on the left.
Yeah.
Why did you switch?
Oh I woke up.
He woke up he says,
after he started doing a podcast and
interviewed guests like Larry Elder.
The most blatant racist example
you can come up with right now.
If cops are more willing to shoot
if the perpetrator is black than white.
What's your data?
What's your basis for saying that?
70% of the homicides are
black on black.
The idea that a racist white cop
is shooting unarmed black people
is a peril to black people
is BS.
And he just beat me
with fact over fact
over fact
about how systemic racism doesn't exist.
Not that racism doesn't exist.
The more people he interviewed,
the more he questioned his former beliefs.
I realize that not everyone
that these people disagreed with could be a racist,
and a bigot, and a homophobe and a sexist,
and that was the argument that was
constantly being laid out.
If there was a Republican that gave a speech and said
"we should lower taxes",
their answer was "he's racist".
Now that actually makes no sense.
Rubin now considers himself a classical liberal.
On his podcasts, he tries to interview people
from the left and the right.
Should government subsidize gay marriage
and straight marriage the same way?
Rubin was surprised that many people on the right
were willing to debate.
For all the differences that we might have,
I'm pro-choice,
most of them are pro-life.
You know, I'm against the death penalty,
most of them are for the death penalty.
They're all willing to sit down and discuss ideas.
When I went from left to libertarian,
the right was willing to argue.
If you believe in the individual,
then you fundamentally understand
that individuals are different, so you are
willing to sit down with someone different than you.
Some of his podcasts last one
or more hours.
I never thought that people would listen
to interviews that long but
millions of people watch.
I didn't know what was gonna happen,
but I started doing more of these long-form interviews
and people kept watching
and then suddenly I realized,
whoa there's a lot of people
that are thinking the things that I'm thinking.
Not just me, by the way, there's
Joe Rogan and there's others.
We're allowing people to go, alright
let's really listen to something,
let's really unpack an idea.
You don't learn anything
when you watch CNN.
You will actually be dumber, having watched CNN.
Alright guys, we're live on the YouTube.
Because the Rubin Report features some
controversial guests,
Milo Yiannopoulos welcome to the show,
and because he
sometimes criticizes leftists,
and maybe because his podcasts are so successful,
his former colleagues now hate him.
You know the right-wing loves him now
because he's a puppet for the right-wing.
He was lazy when he worked here, he's
lazy now with his ridiculous show.
She just sounds envious.
I lost friends.
I still lose friends now.
I mean it's incredible because this goes to
the laziness of the argument of the left.
They believe that if you disagree with them,
that you're evil.
Hate speech does incite violence.
Evil is what these protesters call him.
Ladies, ladies I'll gladly take a question from you.
Have we established that already?
They say just allowing him to speak
is a form of violence.
This woman said Rubin's insensitive
to the victims
on campus.
Biased incidence reports and hate crimes have gone up.
Yeah so.
And people have been spit on,
and people have been threatened,
and people have been told to go home to their country.
It doesn't mean that bad people don't exist,
but tell me about your oppression,
maybe we can work through something.
I mean, tell me about your oppression.
I have no reason to sit and talk about
my own oppression
because that's just like mental energy
that unless I'm going to be paid.
It's an oppression Olympics,
it's a hierarchy of oppressions.
Oppression Olympics.
Yeah, so you've got to figure out how
you are oppressed.
If you have a limp,
you're this much oppressed.
Or if you're a Jew this much oppressed,
or a Muslim
this much oppressed.
Everyone wants to be oppressed.
There's truth behind it.
Blacks have been oppressed,
women, some still are.
Women are sometimes oppressed.
No society is perfect,
but the United States by and large
has given more freedom to more people
from every walk of life
regardless of your skin color,
your sexuality.
We have problems, yes.
We can talk about all of those things,
but to tell me those
are things because you are oppressed,
it ain't true and that idea
needs to be decimated.